[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
National Insider for NFL Network nfl.com
just back from the NFL spring meetings
in Minneapolis Ian Rappaport kind enough
to join us Ian I know the NFL wants to
do away with the kickoff but is there
any other option to sort of keep it in
the game
I don't know that the NFL wants to do
away with the kickoff and I think what
they're doing is to try to make it a
little bit safer but to make sure that
it stays in the game I mean I would say
yesterday for the first time I did hear
at least the possibility
um from commissioner Roger Goodell from
Jeff Miller who's essentially head of
health and safety at the NFL the
possibility of moving on without it but
I think they would like to keep it you
know one thing that's happened is
because kickers have become very good
you've had more returns in the last two
years and you've had in quite a while
therefore you've seen more concussions
so the percentages have increased in
both so I think they'd like to do is
find a sweet spot where maybe there's a
little bit fewer returns fewer
concussions but the play could stay
because it can be really exciting at its
best yeah and I guess if you said that
you were going to take away the onside
kick and you just opened a game uh or
the potential for an onside kick then
would we have kickoffs would the NFL FL
ever consider was starting a football
game at the 25-yard line
I look I mean looking into the future
it's tough to know because there's
plenty of things that happen now in the
NFL where I'm like well I didn't see
didn't see this adjustment didn't see
the you know the points explosion the
sort of emphasis on defensive penalties
I mean there's a lot of things that the
way the NFL has shaped the game that
didn't quite foresee I would be
surprised if we live in a post-kickoff
world and I don't think it's just
because of the onsides kick those are
rare I think it's just because that's
the way we've started the game for 100
years and it can be really exciting I
think they want it to be a little bit
safer and the point from you know these
League officials who spoke yesterday is
when the data points to more concussions
they have to take that part seriously to
figure it out what do you do with punts
I don't believe that the spike in
numbers has been the same for punts as
it's been for kickoffs I think punts
have generally been okay it's the fact
that you know kickers have been
basically getting better at forcing you
to return it so how does the league
adjust from there
the Thursday night Flex certainly got a
lot of headlines here is is this
if all else fails then
then we're going to flex the game or or
do you see or how often do you see a
flex happen no I would say your first
sort of assumption was right it was if
all else fails if we have no other
choice then let's Flex the game and I
think you know the way it was explained
yesterday was there's a high bar for or
whatever it was two days ago there's a
high bar for flexing a Sunday night game
there's a higher bar for flexing a
Monday night game and there's an even
higher bar for flexing a Thursday night
game so like if you said to me right now
what is your guess do we Flex a Thursday
night game this year I would say my
guess is probably not
and then it would go on to the next year
and the one year
um sort of trial would still be in place
and you know we'd sort of move from
there but my guess looking at the
schedule looking at the teams not
knowing anything about quarterback
injuries because you know if it's a
couple third quarterbacks out there you
probably do Flex it but my guess is they
had this whole thing they did this Rule
and they probably don't break the glass
and flex it the third quarterback option
when uh when does that come into play is
that just playoffs that we'll have the
uh third third quarterback option yeah I
mean that that's my guess is you know
for for the regular season you know
teams do have emergency quarterbacks
um and it's sort of fun and you know
it's like when you have a position
player pitching in baseball it's like
it's kind of fun but you really don't
want that to be in the game that means
anything right
um same sort of thing so you know my
guess is it's something that isn't a
thing and we don't hear about because it
can't be a a promotion it has to I mean
it can't be an elevation it has to be a
true promotion it has to be a signed
contract has to be a guy in the 53-man
roster my guess is you don't get that
until like you know weeks 16 17 18 and
then the playoffs when the quarterback
injury and then another one can be like
actually catastrophic
commanders sale still uh on schedule
yeah so this was kind of interesting the
shape that this took so there was all
this consternation debate and discussion
was Dan Snyder going to sell and then he
finds a buyer and then they have an
agreement in principle and then they
have a signed agreement exclusive
agreement with Josh Harris to buy the
team and his Partners to buy the team
and it's basically done and then I get
to Minnesota and people are asking me
like is the sale going to go through you
know the league has some issues and I'm
like yeah I mean they're definitely
working through some things it's a much
more sprawling group than I think the
league is used to there's maybe a little
more debt than the league would like but
no one has suggested to me at all ever
that it's not going through I mean this
thing is going to happen so it was nice
so you get to all that and then Roger
Godot takes the podium yesterday Midway
through the day and says yes he
anticipates a sale going through and to
me it was kind of like okay like went
through this whole thing this big
Journey the deal isn't maybe perfect you
can still massage you can still add more
money add more cash essentially if
that's what the league does want but
like Josh iris is expected to be the new
owner of the commanders and you know I
do believe that is absolutely happening
is the NFL done with Daniel Snyder
uh will be
will be I mean if you're asking me do I
think he would be able to get another
team I would very confidently say
probably not well no the investigation
does that are they they do they still
press on with the investigation yeah
yeah
um you know the Mary Jo White
investigation is ongoing
um all of the legal things you know I
haven't really sensed
any alteration like it's not like okay
he's no longer an owner here so like
pack your stuff up and let's go like I
didn't get that sense I think it's going
to be done to completion and like there
are some reasons for that one like if
Dan Snyder did you know have the
workplace where it seems if there were
the financial if there was some
Financial improprieties you know if if
something was wrong you'd like to know
was wrong and like the people that were
wrong about it to be held responsible
perhaps there could be legal things that
stem from this civil or legal
um you'd certainly like to find that out
if that is true
um you just want to find out like what
was Dan Snyder doing
um and I do think those will go to
completion and then we'll sort of see
you know what becomes of it after that
we were talking about this prior to the
show there used to be quarterback
competitions like true competitions with
teams yeah those are those are long gone
can you is there a quarterback
competition and and with any team right
now that is truly a competition there is
one Tampa I think that's a real
competition you know I mean Baker
Mayfield is in position
um you have Cal trash there
um I think that's going to be a real
quarterback battle I think the problem
is one thing these teams have learned as
they've become smarter is if you're
having a quarterback battle that's not
great
it's really not like
I cannot remember a quarterback battle
where it ended and the guy led the team
to the playoffs or something right like
it's usually what you get is a
quarterback battle from a guy maybe
drafted like in the third round a rookie
in the third or like you know it's a
quarterback battle and then the first
rounder doesn't start but like you know
okay week four or five he's probably
gonna start eventually like that's more
what you get because if you're signing
two guys to just come in and compete and
one of them is going to be your starter
that means either you don't have any
space at all or money at all or you just
didn't do a great job of value and I
think for the bucks this is more of a
sort of retooling collect yourself take
a deep breath get some Financial things
under order a year so quarterback battle
is okay for them but I think for most
teams probably not Ian good to talk to
you again thanks for joining us
awesome absolutely man thanks for having
me Ian Rappaport National Insider for
NFL Network nfl.com just back from the
spring meeting in Minneapolis yeah I go
back to you'd have a quarterback
controversy like the Cowboys Roger
Staubach and Craig Morton and then you
add interchangeable quarterbacks
crazy to think about that but you did
you had two really high-end quarterbacks
competing with each other I think Danny
White was he involved in the quarterback
controversy as well like Gary hogaboom
and Danny white
people took sides yes yeah